>> JOHN, WE ARE TAKING IN THESE
IMAGES TOGETHER AS WE HEARD
THERE FROM BORDER PATROL AND TO
REMIND EVERYONE THAT THE LATEST
NUMBERS SHOWS 6,000 CHILDREN IN
BORDER PATROL CUSTODY AT THIS
TIME.
IT REALLY STOPS YOU IN YOUR
TRACKS WHEN YOU WATCH THIS AND
YOU SEE THE OVERCROWDED
FACILITIES, BABIES, TODDLERS,
CHILDREN OF ALL AGES.
>> WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
TOTAL CURRENT POPULATION THAT’S
AT THE TEXAS FACILITY, THE
PICTURES ARE BLURRED TO CAN’T
READ WHAT’S ON THE SCREEN, 4100
RIGHT THERE, 4100 OF THOSE
PEOPLE IN THE FACILITY ARE
UNACCOMPANIED MIGRANT CHILDREN.
THE CAPACITY DURING A PANDEMIC
FOR THAT FACILITY IS TO HUNDRED
50, SO THEY ARE WAY OVER
CAPACITY AND ALSO, BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE SUPPOSED TO COME INTO
THIS FACILITY TO MISSTATE A
MAXIMUM PERIOD OF 72 HOURS AND
THEN BE TRANSFERRED TO HHS
CUSTODY, THAT’S NOT HAPPENING
QUICKLY ENOUGH.
MORE THAN 2,000 PEOPLE AT THIS
FACILITY HAVE BEEN HELD FOR MORE
THAN 72 HOURS.
THAT WAS THE SUBJECT OF OUTRAGE
BY IMMIGRANTS RIGHTS GROUPS,
OTHER POLITICAL PARTIES, WE’RE
SCREAMING FROM THE ROOFTOPS
ABOUT HOW AWFUL THIS WAS AND YET
WE DO NOT HEAR THE SAME LEVEL OF
OUTRAGE OVER THIS HAPPENING NEW
NOW IN THE NEW MINISTRATION.
>> REMINDED THIS IS ALL
HAPPENING IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC WHERE THERE IS CONCERN
ABOUT COVID BEING BROUGHT ACROSS
THE BORDER AT A TIME WHEN WE ARE
TRYING TO GET A HOLD OF THE
SITUATION HERE.
TO SAFELY CRAM THIS MANY PEOPLE
TOGETHER IF THAT’S EVEN POSSIBLE
.
BUT THEN TO ADD TO IT COVID 19,
WHAT DO YOU DO?
>> AS YOU HEARD THE DEPUTY CHIEF
SAY, THE PEOPLE THEY THAT COME
ACROSS THE BORDER AS MIGRANTS,
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN ARE
INTERVIEWED TO SEE IF THEY WERE
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
CONGRESSMAN LANCE GOODEN WHO WAS
ON EARLIER SAID ONE WAY TO
FIGURE THAT OUT VERY QUICKLY
WOULD BE TO PASS THIS NEW BILL
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE EVERY PERSON
WHO COMES ACROSS THE BORDER HAS
THEIR DNA SAMPLE AND THEN IS
CHECKED WITH THE PERSON THEY
COME ACROSS THE BORDER WITH TO
SEE IF THESE UNACCOMPANIED
CHILDREN OR RATHER CHILDREN
COMING ACROSS AND UP FAMILY
UNITS ARE WHAT THEIR FAMILIES.
>> SO THERE’S FOUR OF THESE
RIGHT NOW.
COULD GET THERE IS USUALLY
BETWEEN FIVE AND SEVEN.
>> THERE YOU SEE A NUMBER OF
MIGRANT CHILDREN.
I ASSUME THESE WOULD BE
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS MOVE
THROUGH TO WHAT WOULD BE THE
HOUSING FACILITY.
I THINK WE ARE GOING TO GET SOME
PICTURES FROM IN THEIR BREADTH
YOU’RE WATCHING SOME REPLAY IT
CAME IN LIVE A FEW MINUTES AGO,
BUT WE WANTED TO SEE WHAT WAS ON
IT THIS AGAIN, ANOTHER VIEW OF
THE INTAKE FACILITY.
THE REAL STORY WILL BE TOLD IF
WE GET INSIDE THE AREA WHERE
THIS MIGRANTS ARE BEING HOUSED
WHICH IS THE PICTURES THAT WERE
LEAKED OUT A LITTLE MORE THAN A
WEEK AGO AND THE PICTURES THAT
TED CRUZ WAS TRYING TO GET WHEN
HE HAD THAT MINISTRATION
OFFICIAL GETTING UP IN HIS FACE
SAYING PLEASE STOP TAKING
PICTURES PLEASE STOP TAKING
PICTURES.
THIS AREA HEARS IS FAIRLY
SPARSELY POPULATED, BUT I THINK
IF THEY GET INSIDE TO THE AREAS
WHERE THE MIGRANTS ARE BEING
HOUSED, YOU MIGHT SEE MORE
GROUTING.
>> IT’S AN IMPORTANT JUST SEE
THESE PICTURES.
BIDEN WAS PRESSED ON THE LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY, WHY WE AREN’T
SEEING INSIDE THESE FACILITIES.
AS YOU CAN SEE, WHEN WE WATCH
THIS TOGETHER, IT GIVES YOU
PERSPECTIVE ON WHAT IT IS LIKE.
FOR US TO SEE FIRSTHAND AND TAKE
THESE IMAGES AND TOGETHER, IT
STORY TELLS THE STORY.
AS AMERICANS WE TAKE THESE
PICTURES AND WE ASK WHAT ABOUT
THE VISIT?
WE KNOW KAMALA HARRIS HAS BEEN
PUT IN CHARGE OF THE BORDER
SITUATION.
WE WERE TOLD ALTHOUGH IT SOUNDS
MORE LIKE SHE WILL BE DEALING
WITH THE COUNTRIES FROM WHICH
THESE MIGRANTS, RATHER THAN
DIRECTLY WITH THE BORDER CRISIS.
WHETHER OR NOT WE WILL SEE A
VISIT ON THE PART OF KAMALA
HARRIS.
WE STILL DON’T HAVE AN ANSWER TO
THAT QUESTION.
SEEING THESE IMAGES PUTS THE
URGENCY ON IT IF YOU DIDN’T
UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS HAPPENING.
>> THERE ARE TWO DIFFERENT TYPES
OF FACILITIES.
THIS IS A BORDER PATROL INTAKE
AND PROCESSING FACILITY.
THIS WAS CONTRACTED ON JANUARY
THE 15TH AND CONSTRUCTION BEGAN
ON JANUARY 19TH.
IT OPENED UP A FEW WEEKS AGO.
IT BECAUSE $6 MILLION TO BUILD
AND $16 MILLION A MONTH TO
OPERATE BECAUSE THEY ARE
OPERATING WAY OVERCAPACITY.
NOW FROM HERE, THE CHILDREN WILL
BE A NUMBER OF THINGS HAPPEN.
THERE ARE TWO FLIGHTS PER DAY
THAT LEAVE THIS FACILITY EACH
HOLDS ABOUT 130 PEOPLE A LOT OF
THOSE ARE MIGRANT FAMILIES.
ONE GOES TO EL PASO AND ONE GOES
TO SAN DIEGO.
BUT THEN WE HEAR ABOUT THE
FACILITY IN SPRINGS WAS WHAT SET
UP DURING THE TRUMP OF
MINISTRATION.
THAT IS AN HHS FACILITY WHERE
UNACCOMPANIED MINOR CHILDREN GO
UNTIL A SPONSOR CAN GO TO TAKE
THEM AND WHILE THEY’RE A SILENT
CLAIM IS ADJUDICATED AND ARE
EITHER REUNITED WITH HER FAMILY
IN THE UNITED STATES OR FAMILY
REMEMBERS RESPONSE.
THE SPRINGS FACILITY, WHICH WE
SAW PICTURES OF LAST WEEK IS NOT